one two three and
dogs love Christmas too
just like me and you know they don't go
shopping or hang up a stocking but
there's lots of things to do out in
Christmas party they all run and bark
because they can hear a slave from a
half a mile away yeah dogs love
Christmas too
when they see old Santa coming all their
tails will wag because he always brings
them doggy treats in his Christmas bag
they all clap their paws when they see
Santa Claus no you just can't hide when
the puppy gets excited dogs love
Christmas too yep
foreign
[Music]
you've been good
have you done
what good dog should
boys and girls
and on you
to be a trusted friend who always will
be true dogs love Christmas too just
like me and you know they don't go
shopping or hang up a stocking but
there's lots of things they do
then one fuzzy puppy cleared his throat
and stepped right up it was Christmas
Day and there was something he wanted to
say he said
translation
dogs love Christmas too
[Music]
thank you